wir haben die ukraine unterstützt wir
werden das tun wir tun es in sehr großem
umfang und auch mit sehr relevanten
waffen und gleichzeitig ist es so dass
wir natürlich immer darauf achten dass
es nicht zu einer eskalation des krieges
kommt und deshalb gibt es schon dem
grundsatz keine alleinige olaf scholz
bleibt bei seiner linie keine
kampfpanzer deutscher herstellung für
die ukraine doch er spricht hier längst
nicht mehr für seine gesamte koalition
nicht nur die außenministerin
widerspricht ihm bemerkenswert deutlich
fordert den zügigen beschluss über
kampfpanzer für kiew aber ein solcher
ist nicht absehbar und selbst die
vorsitzende des verteidigungsausschusses
kann nur rätseln über die beweggründe
von olaf scholz wenn ich es wüsste wären
wir natürlich alle ein stück weiter ich
vermute aber dass der bundeskanzler ich
möchte dass möglicherweise ein deutscher
kampfpanzer einem russischen
gegenübersteht ich darf aber daran
erinnern dass es nicht um die bauart
eines panzers geht oder wer den liefert
sondern wer im panzer sitzt und das sind
ukrainische soldaten die ihr land
verteidigen die spd steht noch
mehrheitlich hinter scholz
flugabwehrkanonen panzer gepard ja mehr
aber nicht doch auch ihr außenexperte
will kampfpanzer liefern und hat eine
idee wie das ohne alleingang
funktionieren könnte wir haben in europa
13 staaten die über rund 2000
leopard-2-panzer verfügen was spricht
eigentlich dagegen wenn sich staaten
bereit erklären gemeinsam ein kontingent
von kampfpanzern zur verfügung zu
stellen die man dann auch rasch an die
ukraine ausliefern könnte die ukraine
die in den letzten zehn tagen
bemerkenswert viel gelände zurück
gewonnen hat steht nun an einer 1300
kilometer langen neuen front solche
deutschen marder und leopard 2 panzer
könnten genau jetzt einen unterschied
machen sagt ausgerechnet ein grüner weil
es einfach besser geschützte konso sind
nämlich es heißt immer ja wir liefern
ihnen ja panzer alter sowjetischer
bauart das schrecklich an diesen panzern
ist die sind so gebaut dass wir in ihren
treffer abbekommen dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit extrem hoch ist dass
die soldaten da drin sterben und deshalb
wird es einen großen unterschied machen
eine besser geschützte panzer wie von
wirbel enttäuschende signale aus
deutschland schreibt der ukrainische
aussenminister und fragt wo vorhat
berlin angst eine frage die auch den
ukrainischen kriegsreporter ilya porno
manko umtreibt warum zögert olaf scholz
dass deutschlands historische
verantwortung eine rolle spielen könnte
lässt er nicht gelten
die vergangenheit ist geschichte wir
sind in einer absolut anderen situation
heute das darf keine entschuldigung
dafür sein ein anderes land das
überfallen wird nicht zu unterstützen
nur weil deutschland seine geschichte
hat
uneingeschränkte unterstützung für
seinen 1 bekommt der kanzler nur noch
von ganz links und rechts der russische
botschafter hat es ja bereits auch schon
gesagt dass damit auch eine rote linie
überschritten ist und damit wären
könnten wir zur kriegspartei werden das
muss man einfach wissen und wir wollen
nicht in einen dritten weltkrieg
rutschen und diese gefahr sehen wer in
den usa vermisst man ganz offenbar
deutsche führung die klare ansage von
der neuen us botschafterin die
entscheidung über die art der hilfen
liegt letztlich bei jedem land selbst
ich lebe ja in washington also ich
glaube ohne irgendwelche quellen
preiszugeben kann ich sagen dort war man
schon reichlich genervt von diesen
nebelkerzen der regierung die devise aus
washington es ist schlicht und
ergreifend die sagt nicht dass ihr nicht
könnt wenn ihr nicht wollt dabei könnte
deutschland beim rüstungshersteller
rheinmetall in unterlüß bei celle stehen
mittlerweile 16 aufbereitete marder
schützenpanzer aus lieferfähig die union
will diese auslieferungen jetzt
erzwingen per abstimmung im bundestag in
der kommenden woche versehen mit einem
harten vorwurf deutschland lässt am ende
die ukraine im stich der kanzler ganz
persönlich im grunde sind wir mit
verantwortlich für viele gefallene für
viele verletzte ließ in der ukraine gibt
und die es nicht geben müsste wenn wir
sie besser ausstatten würden deutschland
schickt geld deutschland schickt waffen
aber die panzer auf die die ukraine so
sehr hofft die schickt olaf scholz
weiterhin nicht